it is not just with regard to netflix
that the cultural arbiters are
determining what the rest of us are
supposed to think and if you question it
then you are labeled intolerant if you
question it then you are labeled outside
the bounds of moral
i discourse
corporations will spend literally
hundreds of millions of dollars in order
to convince you that something is
popular that is not popular right now
they're trying to convince you that the
trans movement the trans rights movement
is extraordinarily popular in the united
states it is not they're trying to
convince you that the movement to
drug your kids at the age of 15
with with hormones and then prepare them
for surgery is popular in america it is
not
they're trying to convince you that
people making jokes is unacceptable most
americans don't believe that
and
like the stubbornness with which these
narratives are pursued is truly telling
my my favorite example is uh is the wnba
so the wnb is not a thing i'm sorry it's
never going to be a thing you can't make
fetch happen it's just never going to be
a thing
in the wnba i'm not saying that women
shouldn't play basketball women can play
basketball but if you're going to
pretend there's a massive market for
women playing basketball and people
watching them you're out of your mind
and the reason you're out of your mind
is because a good high school boys
basketball team could beat a wnba team
i couldn't i suck at basketball but a
good high school boys basketball team
could beat a wnba team
and literally it is a story in the wnba
when somebody dunks it is not even a
story when a high school player dunks in
the boys side
he now again women can play basketball
they're more skilled than i all of that
is fine and dandy but there is this
mainline effort in the media to promote
the notion that the wnba is the thing
when it is clearly not a thing espn
tries to cover the wnba as though it is
equivalent in interest level to any
other major sport
when the wnba's fan
into like singular
is just that a fan
right the the grand total number of
people who care about the wnba are the
executives at the nba who want to
pretend that they care about gender
parity while paying wnba players 40 000
a year and nba players 40 million
dollars a year
and the
immediate families of the people in the
wnba and some very driven feminists who
are apparently willing to sacrifice an
evening of time to watch
somebody play the the
four corners offense essentially okay so
this was made humiliatingly clear
yesterday
so the chicago sky apparently they're a
team in a league that exists
yeah didn't really know or care really
because who who does so they had a
championship celebration so they the
championship celebration started off at
the park
is it millennium park i guess in chicago
and some people showed up no crowd
estimates and then they had a parade
and people were like well you know just
because nobody showed up for the parade
doesn't mean people didn't show up at
the park yes but normally when you have
like a the golden state warriors win an
nba championship people show up for the
parade too
the video of the parade is a deeply
humiliating to the wnba as well it
should be and remember the nba
subsidizes the wnba to the tune of like
tens of millions of dollars every year
um
you if you can't see this there are
buses of people going down the street
open air buses there are four buses
first of all i don't know how big this
team is
there are four buses
no one on the street
no one i mean i like
the assembled
score of people cheered ecstatically as
the buses passed
the assembled small group of people who
could fit in a telephone booth
cheered wildly ah the excitement can you
feel the excitement at the wnba here can
you feel it
wow palpable palpable excitement i mean
people haven't been this excited since
the release of ishtar
the bicyclist and the people honest to
god the people on the top of the bus
wildly outnumber the number of people
who are supposedly cheering them
it's it's really like it's an amazing
sight because they've spent tens of
millions of dollars over the years to
try and make the wnba happen it's not
happening again that is not a rip on the
players because the players have a
certain level of talent and a thing that
is not marketable
i mean sorry
and yet there's an attempt by the
culture to continue to force it down and
it just won't end and watch because i'm
saying this people get very angry at me
because i'm merely pointing out that
there is no crowd for the wnba and no
one cares about the wnb it'll be like uh
you're a sexist that's why you're even
pointing this out
no i'm just pointing out that there are
cultural arbiters who try to tell you
that things are popular that are not
popular and that things are unpopular
when they are popular right netflix is
in real trouble because 12 people walked
out of the netflix headquarters netflix
is in serious trouble and you should
know that next time you think about
telling a joke about transness
but also the wnba is wildly popular so
popular and man people can be so pissed
at you if you make fun of the fact that
no one showed up
by the way it's been a long running joke
that no one watches wnba games i mean
nor mcdonald was making jokes about this
like 20 years ago family guy has an
episode
where they show a wnba game and then it
cuts to
the fan and it's one guy in an empty
stadium
and i'm sorry that's that's right and
it's hilarious the thing about leftist
views of culture is that they run up
against reality but it is also true that
sometimes not always but sometimes if
you just keep pushing and you push hard
enough and you just keep pushing
eventually you shift the entire culture
in your direction which is why you get
the stubbornness and normally if you're
the nba and you run up against the hard
reality and then nobody wants to watch
the wnba just shut it down you're like
okay we could use that money better
elsewhere
but instead you insist on promoting it
because maybe just maybe you will change
the landscape
all right you keep drawing it keep
trying it
and again the cram down from it's a very
small group of people who are trying to
define the cultural taste
it's not working in the case of the wnba
because i mean there's just no way i'm
sorry like there are certain things that
that rational human beings just won't do
rational human beings don't run into
traffic rational human beings don't jump
off of 100 story buildings and rational
people don't watch wnba games almost
forced to do so
but the thing is that this sort of you
know cultural
control does have real world
consequences on a smaller scale and with
regard to particular issues so for
example on college campuses this
continues to be a major problem right it
is this view by the way of things like
the wnba that leads to the title mind
stupidity wherein
sports
is supposed to be equivalent in colleges
between men and women
like that that's that's very silly right
women's softball is not the same as as
men's baseball for example yeah but in
any case
a good example of sort of how the
cultural arbiters decide things comes
courtesy of mit according to the new
york times
michael powell reporting the
massachusetts institute of technology
invited the geophysicist dorian abbott
to give a prestigious public lecture
this autumn he seemed a natural choice a
scientific star who studies climate
change and whether planets in distant
solar systems might harbor atmospheres
conducive to life then a swell of angry
resistance arose some faculty members
and grad students argued that dr abbott
a professor at the university of chicago
had created harm
harm by speaking out against the aspects
of affirmative action and diversity
programs right so people are making the
same claim about this
geophysicist dorian abbott that they're
making about dave chappelle he's
creating harm what was the harm
in videos and opinion pieces dr abbott
has asserted that such programs treat
quote people as members of a group
rather than individuals repeating the
mistake that made possible the
atrocities of the 20th century he said
he favored a diverse pool of applicants
selected on merit
so that
inarguable fact which is that when you
use affirmative action you are treating
people based on group characteristic
rather than individual merit which is
inarguable it is literally the purpose
of affirmative action the purpose of
affirmative action is that black people
historically were discriminated against
therefore we must affirmatively
discriminate in favor of black people in
applications in order to rectify the
breach
he points this out and says that this
cuts directly against the notion of
individual merit and judges people on
the basis of group which has a very ugly
history in the 20th century and this
caused the lecture to be withdrawn
he said that his planned lecture at mit
would have made no mention of his views
on affirmative action but his opponents
in the sciences argued he represented a
quote infuriating inappropriate and
oppressive choice
on september 30th mit reversed course
the head of its earth atmospheric and
planetary sciences department called off
dr abbott's lecture to be delivered to
professors grad students in the public
including some top black and latino high
school students
robert van der hilst the head of the
department at mit said quote besides
freedom of speech we have the freedom to
pick the speaker who best fits our needs
words matter and have consequences
ever more fraught arguments over speech
and academic freedom on american
campuses have moved as a as a flood tide
into the sciences biology physics math
all have seen fierce debates over
courses hiring an objectivity and some
on the academic left have moved to
silence those who disagree on certain
questions
a few fields have purged scientific
terms and names seen by some as
offensive there is a rising call for
citational justice arguing that
professors and grad students should seek
to cite more black latino asian and
native american scholars and in some
cases refuse to acknowledge in footnotes
the research of those who hold
distasteful views that's unbelievable so
you actually have major universities now
deciding whether or not you're allowed
to cite a scientifically useful or
innovative paper based on the race of
the person who wrote that i mean this is
soviet science
there's life centralism the only type of
science that is approved is the science
approved by the state
it's not frankly it sounds like the the
nazi treatment of quote unquote jewish
science right if it comes from the jews
it can't be good science so if it comes
from this white guy it can't be a good
innovative piece of scientific
literature that's insane
i'm not saying it's a prelude to a
holocaust i'm saying that that is a that
is a piece of anti-science
propagandistic trash and it is
undeserving of our of any level of
respect
they're literally saying that they want
to refuse to acknowledge in footnotes
the research of people who hold
distasteful views normally when you
refuse to acknowledge in a footnote
where you're getting a piece that's
called plagiarism joe biden is quite
familiar with it
but apparently they now want you to not
cite people if those people hold outside
views that you don't like
i i hate to break it to these people but
literally every scientist up until the
last five minutes disagreed with them on
politics
i promise you there are things i'm sure
that einstein said that you would
disagree with so i guess you can never
cite einstein again
the decision by mit viewed as a high
citadel of science in the united states
took aback some prominent scientists
debate and argumentation impassioned
even ferocious is the mother's milk of
science they said jerry coyne emeritus
professor of evolutionary biology at the
university of chicago said i thought
scientists would not get on board with
it with the denial of free speech
movement i was absolutely wrong 100
percent
dr abbott spoke of his shock when told
his speech was canceled i didn't know
what to say we're not going to do the
best science that we can if we are
constrained ideologically
no sooner had mit canceled his speech
then robert george director of
princeton's james madison program in
american ideals and institutions invited
him to give the speech there on thursday
the same day as the canceled lecture
dr george says mit has behaved
disgracefully in capitulating to a
politically motivated campaign this is
part of a larger trend of the
politicization of science
and then the story took another turn
this week because david romps a
professor of climate physics at the
university of california berkeley
announced he would be resigning as
director of the berkeley atmospheric
sciences center he said he had tried to
persuade his fellow scientists and
professors to invite abbott
in my view he said there are some
institutional principles we have to hold
sacred
okay but apparently they they did not
want him to
they agreed that this scientist should
not be able to speak
the controversy surrounding dr abbott's
cancer talk speaks as well to attention
manifest in progressive circles between
social justice and free speech some
faculty members have come to see
identity and racial inequities as more
urgent than questions of muzzled speech
phoebe cohen is a geosciences professor
and department chair at williams college
one of many who expressed anger
on twitter at mit's original decision to
invite dr abbott to speak cohen agreed
dr abbott's views reflect a broad
current in american society ideally she
said a university should not invite
speakers who do not share its values on
diversity and affirmative action nor was
she enamored of mit's offer to let him
speak at a later date to the mit
professors
to me the professional consequences are
extremely minimal she said
what she was asked of the effect on
academic debate should the academy serve
as a bastion of unfettered speech
here is her answer and this is
everything quote this idea of
intellectual debate and rigor as the
pinnacle of intellectualism comes from a
world in which white men dominated
that is
insane
i'm sorry that's insane it's also racist
if the idea of intellectual debate and
rigor is restricted to white people or
as a white people invention that is the
most you know who agrees with that david
duke that is the most racist thing i
have read today for sure
that is insane
intellectual rigor and debate as a
pinnacle of intellectualism if it had
been up to apparently the people of
color around the world these things
would be a very low priority you mean
science
and people debating idea wow what a
statement but again these are these are
the people who hold power in a wide
variety of institutions
and eventually that will have an impact
on how we live not just at the
universities not just with regard to
companies like netflix but the kind of
content you can consume
the kind of things you're allowed to say
out loud you wonder why people are
living in political fear right now
that's why people are living in
political fear right now we all know it
and this stuff has real world
consequences it's going to have
political consequences as well the left
is constantly saying things like why do
you even care about this there's this
gaslighting effect why do you care about
this why are you paying attention to the
cultural cram downs after all you don't
have to pay attention until you make me
pay attention you will be made my friend
eric erickson suggested you will be made
to care
hands off is not a policy that redounds
to your own benefit at this point
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed